llegó el momento de hablar de revista de
prensa con rosa pérez más de burro
shuffle y jueves ya estamos casi
finalizando la semana empezamos entonces
con el escándalo en torno a crisis como
el presentador estrella de la cadena cnn
rosa que ha pasado bueno es raúl primero
hace falta aclarar un poco sus vínculos
familiares y destacar que crisis como
que es una estrella de esta cadena de
estadounidense de hecho el presentador
del programa de crisis prime time no lo
es entonces que sé que lo conoces de ese
hermano del ex gobernador de nueva york
andrew cuomo que recordemos acabó
dimitiendo por las acusaciones de acoso
sexual que fueron hasta puede ser la
fiscalía del estado de nueva york bien
ya se sabía que el presentador crease
como había ayudado a su hermano en
cierto modo a navegar esa tormenta lo
que sucedió es que este lunes pasado se
dieron a conocer nuevos informes de la
fiscalía del estado de nueva york que
mostraban como el presentador de 100
había tenido un rol más activo de lo que
se sabía hasta el momento en la defensa
mediática de su hermano podríamos decir
por lo que la cadena ha decidido
suspenderlo de momento de forma
indefinida rosa vamos entonces a hablar
seguimos hablando de ese tema o ya
pasamos a seguir hablando
exacto bueno siendo y si lo que hace es
una cuestión pues más factual explicando
de qué ha ido todo el escándalo pero
podemos ir también a ver el new yort el
que fue uno de los medios bueno fue de
hecho el primero que reveló todas estas
denuncias contra el ex gobernador del
estado de nueva york y de hecho pues el
'new york times' lo que destaca es que
tienen no estaba preparada para esta
para esta revelación es esta nueva
revelación de documentos de la fiscalía
y que de hecho el presidente del
ascienden asumió directamente la
decisión de suspender a su presentador
estrella y que eso fue un cambio radical
respecto a la línea que habían mantenido
hasta el momento si bien la cadena había
admitido que no estaba bien que como
defendiera a su hermano pues había
defendido un poco pues a su imagen
insignia y es que recordemos las nuevas
revelaciones que se han dado conocer es
que el presentador utilizó sus fuentes y
sus vínculos con los medios de
comunicación para saber si y más
revelaciones que atacarán a su hermano y
también para tener información sobre las
mujeres que lo denunciaron y en este
sentido titular en la new yorker raúl
ahora vamos a hablar dos desde new
yorker el código de cristian de cromo el
artículo es escrito por eric launch
exacta y lo que señala es que si bien
pues los asuntos de crisis como son los
medios de comunicación y los de andrew
cuomo la política y que ambos campos no
deberían mezclarse pues que
evidentemente en este caso se se entra
en juego asuntos familiares por lo que
esta línea se difumina pero es que de
hecho destaca una declaración de crisis
como del presentador de senent que dice
red de hecho no hay división entre la
política y los medios todos nos
conocemos entre todos algo que sucede
sobre todo en medios de comunicación
nacionales y destaca una discusión que
consta en estos documentos que es que el
investigador de la fiscalía pregunta a
cuomo en una declaración jugada en
juradas y preguntó a su hermano por los
detalles de sus acusaciones él dijo que
no el investigador pregunta por qué y
dice pues me incomoda rosa vamos a
hablar ahora de un tema de pederastia en
iglesia en colombia amos o con un
artículo de conectas la lista que
escondía la iglesia de medellín los
curas denunciados por pederastia y abuso
sexual
exacto esta es una investigación entre
conectas y vorágine y en lo que es lo
que sacan a la luz estos dos medios
colombianos son 43 en nombres de
religiosos vinculados con las denuncias
de agresiones sexuales contra menores y
estos 43 nombres los han obtenido entre
distintas fuentes por un lado la propia
fiscalía de colombia por otro lado la
diócesis que estuvo obligada a
proporcionar pues algunos de sus
registros tanto como por fuentes
protegidas algunos de los supervivientes
les animamos pues a entrar en este
artículo y el leerlo porque es bien
extenso y detallado una gran labor de
investigación vamos con
brasil-elecciones 2022 o carta capital
lula crece y también vencería cualquiera
mientras que moro súper ácido en el
tercer lugar supera ha sido en el tercer
lugar
esta es ya un poco una especulación de
cara a lo que serían las elecciones
presidenciales de 2022 en brasil si
finalmente lula da silva es el candidato
del pp y lo que señala esta nueva
encuesta realizada por atlas político es
que bullock quedaría con un 50 por
ciento de los votos frente a bolsonaro
que tendría un 30 por ciento y por otro
lado que también ganaría a moro
recordemos sergio moro es el juez que lo
encarceló y que después la corte suprema
dijo que no había sido imparcial en el
proceso judicial hablamos por supuesto
de micrón con eso terminamos al yazira
mapa mundial de las nuevas restricciones
por esta variante exacto mira raúl como
se van avanzando estas restricciones van
cambiando constantemente a pesar de que
la oms se ha pedido que no se continúe
con esta discriminación por países a
quien al yazira tenemos un mapa sobre
pues las regulaciones las nuevas
restricciones que ha implantado cada
país aquí podemos ver como china japón
pues han implantado cierres más
estrictos y otros países como eeuu por
ejemplo pues
ponen pues más filtros en función de los
países rosa gracias por toda la
información en esta revista de prensa
nos vemos mañana con más ahora vamos a
saludar en nuestro primer invitado el
día